Okay. We've already talked
about the problems of using
these texts. Historically.
If you remember early in the semester,
we talked about Galatians one and two
and acts and we tried to compare exactly
when did Paul go where, uh, with
regard to Jerusalem, Damascus,
Antioch,
and we saw that it's a very,
very difficult to harmonize Galatians
one and two with the account of acts and
Paul's movements around Jerusalem.
We've also got a lot of other situations
where this would be very difficult.
I mentioned,
um,
the difference between Matthew and Luke
as far as the birth narratives according
to just to try to figure
out how this would work.
If you took the birth narratives of
Matthew and Luke, it would be very,
very difficult to find out historically
what happened. Uh, so for example,
if you just take, Matthew
is, I've said before,
his family seems to simply
be in Bethlehem. It doesn't
say they're from Galilee.
It doesn't say they're originally from
Nazareth, there just in Bethlehem,
and they're in Bethlehem.
Well before Jesus is born,
because the wise men and the east to see
the star and it takes them enough time
to travel from Persia.
We're supposed to understand from the
narrative because they're called mad jai.
And those are Wiseman from
Persia all the way to Jerusalem.
They meet up with King Herod the Great,
uh, he, he gets his wise men to consult.
They then find that they're
supposed to go to Bethlehem,
they journey to Bethlehem,
and then they get their, uh,
not long after Jesus was born. So
according to Matthew, you don't,
you don't have any time actually in
the narrative of Matthew for the whole
moving from Nazareth to
Bethlehem narrative that you
get in the gospel of Luke.
You just don't have time in Matthew.
They're just there. And then, uh,
the angel appears to
Joseph in a dream and says,
Herod's going to kill all the babies.
So Joseph takes the family,
they moved to Egypt for a while. He
gets another dream years later. What,
how many years? Who knows, but, uh,
saying that Herod the great is now dead.
So they go back,
they start to go back to Bethlehem
because it says that's their home, right?
They go back home, they're going
to go to Bethlehem. Instead,
they moved to Galilee to avoid Herod's
son who was at the time according to
Matthew,
ruling in Judea.
That's the sort of narrative you
get to Luke. It's very different.
They're from Nazareth. That's sort
of Mary's hometown is Nazareth.
All the pregnancy of Jesus takes
place with Marian Nazareth.
She even goes to Judea to visit
her. Ken's woman, Elizabeth, uh,
who's the mother of John the Baptist
according to the gospel of Luke.
And then she goes back to Nazareth and
then it's according to this census,
the world census that they go to Bethlehem
and it's why they're in Bethlehem in
the stable because you don't
have a stable in Matthew,
you there just maybe in a home or
according to a lot of traditions, uh,
Jesus was, there was a cave somewhere
and that Jesus was born in, but in,
it's in Luke that you get the whole
story about the Christmas store.
About the stable that Jesus is born
in because there's no room in the end.
They stay in that area for a month.
We know that because it says that they
first have Jesus circumcised on the
eighth day from his birth and in the time
of purification takes place according
to Leviticus,
which was about a month long.
They take Jesus to the presentation
in the temple in Jerusalem,
and it's after that,
so a month or so after his birth that
they then move back home to Nazareth.
Now there's no way you can basically get
these two narratives to fit together in
any respectable historical way. Does that
mean that nobody's ever tried to do it?
No.
Of course you've got all kinds of very,
very smart fundamentalists who believe
that the new testament has to be accurate
in every historical and scientific
detail or they believe that it's not.
It can't be scripture and they will figure
out some way to try to make sure that
both these narratives can be fit together.
But what I'm telling you is
that no reputable historian
will accept this because
you just have to fudge that stuff
too much. You have to fudge the data.
So what do we believe
about the birth of Jesus?
Most of us think we don't know
anything about the birth of Jesus.
All the Christmas stories
or later tradition. The pro,
probably the one thing that most of us
would say is that Jesus probably was from
Nazareth.
His family was simply from Nazareth
because he's called Jesus of Nazareth.
And the traditions that got him to
Bethlehem for his birth are probably later
positivistic traditions, uh, that Matthew
and Luke later developed for different,
for different reasons.
But to get Jesus born in Bethlehem
for fulfillment of prophecy reasons.
So if you take the, the births of the
birth of Jesus is in Luke and Matthew,
it's from a historical point of view.
It's impossible really to harmonize
them without coming up with fantastic,
unbelievable,
uh,
conjugations of Jesus moving back and
forth to Egypt in the holy family and all
this sort of thing.
We get lots of other kinds
of things about this too.
What are some obvious historical
problems with the historical Jesus?
Well,
one of the things is the trial of Jesus.
There are different versions of the
trial of Jesus in the Gospels and
unfortunately,
basically most scholars will say that we,
we don't really know what
happened to the trial of Jesus.
We don't even know for sure whether
there was any kind of official trial.
It may have been that he was just
arrested in the middle of the night.
He was just then they've given
permission to be crucified.
He was crucified the next day. That would
be the sensible way of doing things.
You didn't have to have the Romans
didn't need elaborate trials in order to
crucify Jews who are rabble
rousers in the first century.
They did it all the time, but if you
look at some of the details of the trial,
notice how they're very different.
Mark 14 get your bibles out.
Today we are talking about
the historical Jesus,
but I'm not just going to
tell you what I believe,
what scholars believe
about the historical Jesus.
I'm going to try to show you why
scholars come up with ideas that we have,
how we get there.
What is our method for arriving
at historical Jesus discussions?
So look at mark 14 verse 53
I'm
the wrong person.
They took Jesus to the high
priest and all the chief priests,
the elders and the scribes were assembled.
Peter had followed him at a distance,
right into the courtyard of the high
priest and he was sitting with the guards,
warming himself at the fire. Now the
chief priests and the whole counselor,
we're looking for testimony against
you is to put them to death.
But they found none for many
gave false testimony against him.
And their testimony did not agree.
Some students,
Ben gave false testimony against
him saying, we have heard him say,
I will destroy this temple
that is made with hands.
And in three days I will build another,
not made with hands,
but even on this point,
their testimony did not agree.
Then the high priest stood up before them
and that's Jesus have, you know, answer.
What is it that they testify against you?
But he was silent and did not answer
again. The high priest asked him,
are you the Messiah, the son of
the blessed one? Jesus said, I am.
And you will see the son of man seated
at the right hand of power and coming
with the clouds of heaven.
That's a quotation from Daniel.
So Jesus basically just says, I
am. And then quotes Daniel. Uh,
and then it says,
the high priest accused him of prophecy.
And then look at Chapter 15 beginning
of chapter 15 as soon as it was morning,
the chief priests heard of consultation
with the elders and scribes and the
whole council. They bound Jesus, let
him away and handed him over to pilot.
Pilot asked him, are you the king of
the Jews? He answered him. You say,
so then the chief priest accused him.
Many things. Pilot asked me again,
have you know, answer, see how many
charges they bring against you.
But Jesus made no further apply.
So that ply pilot was amazed.
Now notice all Jesus says at his trial,
according to mark,
the oldest of our written testimonies
is I am. And a quotation of scripture.
At one point and then so you say,
and the next trial before pilot.
Now compare that to what goes
on in the gospel of John.
I mentioned this a bit in my lecture
on the gospel of John Howard.
It's narrative details are very
different from the synoptic gospels.
One of the places where this is really
different is the trial of Jesus.
John 18 verse 19 not gonna read all of
this because it's just way too long.
This is part of the,
the interesting thing is that the trial
of Jesus goes on for a long time in the
gospel of John. The high priest
questioned Jesus about his disciples,
about his teaching. Jesus answered,
I have spoken openly to the world.
I have always taught in synagogues
and the temple where all the Jews come
together. I have said nothing in
secret. Why do you ask me already?
Jesus has said a ton more now.
Then he said in the other gospels at his
trial, but then he just keeps going on.
Uh, they hey said some more
things when he had said this.
One of the police standing near
by struck Jesus face thing.
Is that how you answer the high priest?
Jesus answered if I have spoken
wrongly testified to the wrong,
but if I have spoken rightly,
why do you strike me?
Then Anna sent him bound to
Caiaphas the high priest.
So according to John Annas and Caiaphas
or kin folk and they're sort of both
members of the high priestly
family. So you can go on and on, uh,
at 28, verse 28, um,
is the trial before, uh,
they took Jesus to pilot.
Pilot went out to the Junes that what
accusation do you bring against this man?
The answered if this
man were not a criminal,
we would not have handed him over to you.
Pilot said to them,
take him yourselves and judgment
corn to your law. The Jews answered,
we are not permitted, blah,
blah, blah, blah, blah. It
goes on. Pilot talks to Jesus.
Are you the king of the Jews? Jesus
answered, do you ask this on your own?
Did not or did others tell you
about pilot? Said, I'm not a Jew,
am I your own nation? And the chief
priests had know you over to me.
What have you done?
Jesus said,
my kingdom is Jesus just has a
whole conversation with pilot,
which leads to that wonderfully a quotable
phrase that everybody knows about.
Where,
uh,
finally Jesus talks about truth and
pilots says in a phrase that could be
sincere or a lot of people answered
as being cynical. What is truth?
Very famous quotation from the
gospel of John. And then of course,
there's a whole passage interview
seeing the, uh, the, uh,
Jesus Christ superstar,
the player, the movie.
There's a whole scene where Herod,
this is actually the son
of Herod the great now,
but there's a trial before Herod also
in the gospel of John. Not Really,
uh,
in market all but in the gospel of John.
You get this whole trial before Herod
and of course to Jesus Christ superstar.
This is when Herod kind of dances around
on this raft and has show girls and
they all do this. So you are the Christ,
the great Jesus colonized, you know,
prove to me that Jordan,
oh fool.
Walk across Mott's women pool
and all that sort of thing.
So there's a whole scene
and Jesus Christ superstar,
the whole scene wouldn't be
possible without the gospel
of John Because it's not
in the other gospels.
So this is a famous scene.
All of that's different in John.
So what's historical, how to cook,
how to scholars decide you have
these very, very different,
was Jesus completely silent at his trial
as it seems to be in the gospel of Mark?
Did he not offer,
um,
any reasons for what he did or did
he have theological and philosophical
discussions with pilot about his message?
What's historical in that case?
Basically most historians
are going to say,
none of it is none of the trial stuff.
Can we be confident would
be historical for one thing,
that we just have this very,
very differences.
But there's one very little interesting
piece of evidence about this.
According to all the gospels,
where were the disciples
after Jesus was arrested?
Anybody remember,
they've almost the,
the gospel say that the disciples
ran away at the arrest of Jesus.
So maybe according to psalms revisions,
according to these traditions,
maybe Peter was there sort of in a
courtyard out removed from the trial,
but none of the disciples of Jesus
would have allowed to be present at any
trial. Whether it was as
high priest, our pilot,
they wouldn't have been allowed in.
These were peasants from
Galilee there fishermen,
they don't go walking
into pilots headquarters.
So who would have been there to
report these different trial things?
There are no stenographers in the ancient
world sitting down taking notes of
these trials.
There are no cry court records.
There are no journalists.
Nobody was there who later Christians
had access to so that they could possibly
have known what went on in the trial.
So according to most historians who just
say all of this trial stuff was very
much made up by later Christians.
Why?
Because they figured you had to have
a trial if you're going to have Jesus
condemned. And so they figured, well,
what would have taken
place these gospel writers,
or maybe they're using traditions
that developed before them,
they're using traditions that developed
because people just say, well,
what would have happened at Jesus' trial?
What's likely to have happened?
And then they make up that likeliness
and they put that into the story. Now.
So you've got a couple of different
situations where we, historians are very,
very skeptical about some of the basic
aspects of the gospels accounts as far as
what they tell us about the historical
Jesus, the birth narratives.
We just throw up our hands,
the trials before pilot. Nope,
probably none of it rises
to the level of history.
But this leads to a couple
of different problems.
The first one we'll talk about is,
so what,
and I'm saying this because once his,
once critical scholars tart
talking about the historical Jesus,
we immediately start
stepping into sand traps.
On the one hand we have good Christian
people who are a bit of a fray,
a bit afraid that if you start questioning
there was historical reliability of
the gospels, then you're going to
undermine every aspect of Christian faith.
If the birth narratives are not,
as they say they are in the gospels,
then how can you trust
any of it to be true?
And if none of it is true, how do we even
know that Jesus actually even existed?
Or even if he did exist,
how do you know that he wasn't a
liar or a magician or just a bum?
How do you, if that's
true, why have faith?
Why not just give up the whole thing?
So on the one hand,
you've got Christians who
are very threatened by using
typical historical tools
on the gospels and the very
question of the historical Jesus.
On the other hand,
we have just as many people who are
anti Christian and who they want to grab
onto this and say,
Aha.
Notice how reputable scholars
like Dale Martin Woolsey,
professor of religious studies at Yale
University points out that not everything
in the gospels is reliably history.
Well that means is all a bunch of bunk
and every Christian in the world is
basing their faith on things that
are known by scholars to be lies.
Well that's not exactly right either.
Is it so on both,
but on both sides you get some people
who say who grab on to any sort of idea
that of his,
that historians would say,
these are the discrepancies in the gospels
are these are places where we don't
have historical evidence to back us up
and they want to run with that precisely
in order to impugn the
faith of Christians now,
so scholars have to be very careful
what we basically want to say there.
There was actually a one or two scholars
in the 19th century reputable scholars.
Bruno Bauer was one of them,
a German scholar who denied
that Jesus ever existed.
He just said it was all,
even the person of Jesus was
a myth created by the church.
And you'll find every once in a
while somebody on the, you know,
on the web or internet or
something, uh, or in some, you know,
crazy blog saying that Jesus never existed
but reputable historical scholars all
admit that Jesus of Nazareth existed.
There was a guy back there,
Jesus of Nazareth. There's just too
much evidence that existed and it's uh,
just not controvertible when it comes
to reliable historical evidence.
But that's a big difference from
saying, yes, we believe he existed.
And there's some things we think we can
say about him to accepting all of the
gospel materials as reliable.
So scholars basically are
caught in the middle of saying,
we believe there was a Jesus of Nazareth.
We believe we might even be able to say
some things as historians about who he
was, what he said, what he did,
why he may have been executed
and that sort of thing.
But that means we have to use critical
historical tools to analyze these faith
based text, these theological texts.
What are indeed in some cases,
mythological text.
We read theological text to try to figure
out what we can say historically and
that leads to the other issue.
I keep saying the historical Jesus because
a whole lot of people have the idea
that once I give you the historical Jesus,
then you've got the real Jesus.
You've got Jesus as he really was and
thought therefore Jesus has it really is.
Now,
the problem with that is that theologians
and I can put on my historical hat
most of the time, cause I actually
have a job as a historian.
I don't really have a job as a theologian,
so I kind of call myself
sometimes an amateur theologian,
but if I want to put on my
amateur theologian hat, I
can make a case for you. Why?
The historical Jesus is not a very
good foundation for Christian faith.
It's not reliable as a
foundation of Christian faith,
it's not sufficient as a foundation for
Christian faith, the theological Jesus,
the Jesus of Christian confession
is not the historical Jesus.
The Jesus of theological confession is
that Jesus that matches what the Church
has traditionally believed about Jesus.
So for example,
Jesus that matches the creeds.
A Jesus matches Christian confessions.
So one of the most important things for
Christian confession, for example, is, uh,
would you lose your faith if you,
if you believe that Jesus wasn't born
in Bethlehem but was rather important,
Nazareth problem, most, most Christians
would probably say, well, no,
that's not really that important.
What's the most central thing for
most Christians, the Christian faith?
Do you believe that somehow God was in
Jesus Christ reconciling the world to
himself to quote the Apostle Paul,
or do you believe that Jesus Christ is
divine? Do you believe that Jesus is God?
Do you believe that Jesus is
God incarnate God in the flesh?
That's a fundamental aspect of
Christian faith for most Christians.
But notice that's not something that
historians can pronounce about one way or
another.
There's no possible way that I practicing
history by the normal historic,
graphical tools of history could tell
you whether God was in Jesus Christ.
Is there, I mean, just think
about it. How would I test that?
How would I figure it out?
What would count as a positive proof?
What would count as a non controvertible
negative truth? There's no such thing.
So when I'm talking to you
about the historical Jesus,
I have to get over several hurdles.
One of the hurdles is trying to show
you that the historical Jesus is a
construction made by historians
practicing the typical trade of modern
historians. It's just like
for example, if I say,
what's the historical Socrates?
We don't,
we don't have direct assets to Socrates
either, right? Socrates left no writings.
All we know about Socrates are
mainly the things that either Plato,
his disciples said about
him are xenophobic.
Another of his disciples said
about him and a few other things.
And you know what? Plato and Xenophon
don't give the same picture of Socrates.
So figuring out what does,
who is the historical Socrates is also
a difficult historical question that
historians debate about.
So that's the one thing is just using
typical historical data. So, for example,
if I say we're going to talk about
George Washington and we're going to talk
about the George Washington,
that hit of history,
the George runs with the
historians will come up with,
that's a different George Washington.
Then say,
let's talk about the George
Washington of popular American piety,
the George Washington of popular American
piety through a dollar across the
Potomac.
No historian believes that
George Washington through a
dollar across the Potomac,
at least not Mount Vernon.
If you've been to mount Vernon,
you know that's a superhuman
feat. Historians, you know,
in popular American Piety,
George Washington is a little
boy chopped down the cherry tree.
And when his father got onto me, he said,
I cannot tell a lie. Father it is I.
That's a George Washington is the
George Washington of American popular
tradition. And it's important to know
about that, about George Washington.
No historian believes that
George Washington as a
child actually chopped down
the treachery.
And that happened and that happened.
And mainly because we actually found
the preacher who made up the story for a
sermon.
It made a good sermon point,
nevermind motto.
What's the motto of the Class Day?
Omni Boosie doobie tandem, especially
when you're listening to preachers
are professors.
So the historical Jesus is not the
same thing as the theological Jesus.
So that's one point to remember another.
This is another theoretical issue,
and this is very confusing for some
people when you first start thinking about
it.
We often use the word history in two
different ways and common English.
We,
we often use the word history to
refer simply to stuff in the past.
So for example,
the civil war is historical.
That just means it happened in the past.
Yeah,
that's one way of you art history,
but it's kind of a sloppy way
because if I want to say the history,
the history of the civil war,
I'm not really talking in that
case of the whole civil war, right?
A historical account of the civil war
is something is a narrative that will be
constructed by a historian to represent
a story about whatever happened in the
past, but it can't
replicate the past. Right?
In order to replicate the civil war,
you would have to actually have the full,
what, four years, wasn't it? Four years,
however long the civil war took the fight.
You'd have to have that amount of time
because every tiny detail, every action,
every person, every word, every
letter, everything anybody said,
all every tiny battle,
every ant that crawled over a decomposing
corpse is part of the past of the
civil war.
That's not the history of the civil war.
That's the civil war as
it occurred in the past.
The history of the civil war is an account
of whatever happened in the past that
a historian constructs
and then tells you so.
When we use the word history in
that more professional sense,
we're not talking about the past. We're
talking about an account of the past.
So often philosophers of history like
to separate these two words out and
they'll use the word passed for the
event that occurred in the past.
They'll use the word history for an
account of the event that occurred in the
past. Now notice what that means.
Histories are assessable to us,
right? You can go to the store and
buy a history of the civil war.
You can buy a history of George Washington
and you can buy a history of Jesus
Christ.
Does the history of the civil war that
you buy in the store give you the civil
war? No. It gives you an
account of the civil war.
This, the actual civil war is radically
in assessable to you. It's inaccessible.
You can't get it.
Think about this.
How would you actually recover
the actual of the civil war?
How would you do it? Let's say you
can't travel in time, like in TV,
let's just say that hypothetically.
Yeah.
Does the civil war exists somewhere in
space where the light that is emitted
from it is still flying off in the
universe somewhere and if you could faster
than the speed of light
fly out to that thing,
you could actually experience the
civil war as it actually happened.
Well, maybe theoretically, but for
any of us sitting here in this room,
that's not possible.
Is it? In other words,
this is a radical thought to some people,
but the past no longer
exists for you and me,
it's radically gone.
The past is non existent.
Yeah.
When it comes to our
experiences of it all,
we can experience our
different accounts of the past.
We can experience different
constructions of the past.
We cannot experience the past itself.
It's gone.
It's lost to us forever.
That means the historical Jesus as
Jesus actually existed in history is in
assessable to you. You will not
find him. You cannot find him.
You will never find him.
What you can do is using the trades
that the tricks of the trade of modern
historiography,
you can play by the rules of modern
historiography and you can construct a
historical Jesus.
That means a Jesus of Nazareth constructed
using the same kinds of historical
tools as historians would use to construct
the historical George Washington,
the historical Socrates, the historical
Plato, the historical Abraham Lincoln.
That's a construction though.
So those theoretical points are very
important because when I talk about the
historical Jesus,
you cannot think like most popular people
think that what I'm talking about is
the real Jesus. The
Jesus, as he really was,
are certainly not the
Jesus of Christian faith.
What I'm giving you is an account of
Jesus that modern historians construct
using the typical tools
of modern historiography.
That's a lot of theoretical
philosophy of history,
stuff that I tried to boil down
and straight forward language.
Is there any question or comments
about that before I go on?
All that stuff is necessary though,
because people,
especially when they
turned to objects of faith,
did you start asking historical questions?
People's minds start turning into mud.
All right,
now let's just jump right in.
What could we say about the historical
Jesus as historians? I'm today.
I can't give you the whole thing
if you want the whole thing,
all the answers to life.
Uh,
well I won't give you cooking
and that kind of thing.
But if you want all the
answers to historical Jesus
stuff as it comes from the
Export Wa,
you can take my seminar in the fall
that I'll be teaching on the historical
Jesus a whole semester just on
the historical Jesus question.
So I'll do that in the fall.
I'm going to give you in the next 20
minutes a little version of sort of the
results.
I'll show you some of the results that we,
that I would say about the historical
Jesus. And I'd also say that Bart Erhman,
the author of your textbook will agree
with most of this in his chapter in your
textbook.
If you want more of that.
Bart Ehrman has a book on
the historical Jesus called,
I think it's called Jesus of Nazareth,
the third apocalyptic
prophet of a new millennium.
It's also published by Oxford press.
It's several years old,
but he and I agreed to a great
extent about this sort of thing.
So if you want more of
this, you can look at, uh,
Bart's book and it'll pretty much agree
with a lot of this stuff that I'm going
to say. Or you can take my seminar next
fall. So here are some things that we,
I think we can agree about.
Most historians might agree about that.
The historical Jesus,
and then I'll tell you how we got there.
So we're going to talk about first some
results and then some methodology. First,
the sign on the cross.
Does anybody remember what the sign on
the Cross when Jesus is crucified says,
pardon?
Say it again.
Jesus of Nazareth. King of the
Jews. Anybody else? What did,
what did you say?
You're not here lies,
but there's one versus this is Jesus
and Netapp and it's because the four
different gospels have
slightly different wording,
but they all have something version of
Jesus of Nazareth, King of the Jews,
which is of course why you sometimes
see this abbreviated from the Latin,
right?
If you've seen it in churches
injury. Have you ever seen that on a
cross or something like that in a church?
Yeah. Jesus of Nazareth
in Latin. Rex King.
Your dorm of the Jews.
So that.
Notice how though it's slightly different.
Let's look, if you've got your bibles,
it's mark 1526 if you've got
a parallel version throat,
I'm going to be looking at Throckmorton
cause it has the synoptic parallels.
It's Throckmorton paragraph two 49 but
somebody put your finger on mark 1526
it's also Matthew 27 37
yeah,
it's also Luke 2138
and it's also John 1919
now in Mark 1526 it says the inscription
of the charge against him read the king
of the Jews. That's it. And
it goes on to buy this stuff.
Look over right next to it. Ah,
on Matthew says over his head,
they put the charging per se. This
is Jesus, the king of the Jews.
So it's slightly different.
Luke 23
what'd I say? 38 there it is a hump.
There was also an inscription over him.
This is the king of the Jews.
And who has the John Version?
John 1919 did anybody put
their finger on John 1919
Jesus of Nazareth.
King of the Jews.
And doesn't it say in John that it was
in different languages or am I ready to
frigging that's right. Hebrew, Latin
and Greek and the gospel of John.
So that's what we've got.
What are the things that most scholars
will say is we think that's historical.
And why do we think it's
historical? Well, for one thing,
it comes from at least two
independent sources, right?
What are the two independent
sources that it comes from?
It's in all four gospels, but all four
gospels aren't independent sources,
are they? Right. Because we believe
that Matthew and Luke used mark.
So if Matthew and Luke copied it from
mark, that makes mark one source.
Did the author of John
Hughes The Gospel of Mark?
Not according to the theory we're using
in this class. Some people might say, yes,
some scholars might tickets,
but in this class we're going on the
theory that the gospel of John Probably
didn't use mark as one of his sources.
So you've got the gospel of
John is one source for this.
You've got the gospel of mark
is another source for this.
So you have to have what scholars are
willing to treat as independent sources,
which both had this nice little
piece of data is data right there.
Now the other thing is that it
might be interesting to you,
for you to know king of the Jews is
not a Christological title that early
Christians used about Jesus
and the gospels who sit in it.
And we've seen a lot of different
titles for Jesus. He's the teacher,
he's the son of God, he's the
Messiah, he's the holy one of Israel.
We just saw he has a lot of things and
these things are obviously things art of
Christians called him Lord.
They called him son of God,
but they didn't call him king of the Jews.
It was one of the titles
of Jesus that are the,
apparently the earliest followers
of Jesus didn't latch onto.
So we don't see it in the, in the, uh,
letters of Paul and we don't
see it elsewhere in the gospels.
So what scholars have said is,
look,
this thing king of the Jews doesn't
look like a Christological confessional
title that Christians made up
and then put into the Gospel.
It goes against the tendency of the
Christian writers themselves because it's
not one of their titles. If it had
said, this is Jesus of Nazareth,
the Lord of Heaven and earth,
then scholar who say, well,
that sounds like a Christian confession,
but saying Jesus of Nazareth,
King of the Jews doesn't sound
like a Christian confession.
So it goes against the tendency of the
riders themselves and then we say, well,
maybe then it's historical.
Maybe it's a little glimpse
of history sitting in there.
So that's one thing that
the sign on the cross,
most scholars say that's historical.
Now talk about why that's important.
It's a very small detail, but it
could be very important. Yes sir.
It could have. Exactly. In other
words, in the SA, the question was,
didn't this come from the mocking terms
in the trial? That's exactly right.
The Christians, if you notice, it's
the people who are mocking Jesus,
who call him king of the
Jews. And so why, you know,
this is not something that the Christian
writers want to invent and then put in
the story
exactly that supports that point.
So that is a nice little detail.
One of the things that scholars
often say may well be historical.
Jesus was baptized by John The baptist.
Now notice how,
why would scholars say this is historical?
Well,
there's not complete agreement
about how it happened.
There's the gospel of John doesn't exactly
tell you about the baptism of Jesus
by John, but it has Jesus and his
disciples also baptized in the Jordan,
and it has Jesus very much connected to
John the Baptist in the beginning of his
gospel. The other gospels do
have Jesus baptized by John.
But notice how the story goes along.
All of the writers who
has the gospel of John,
who have Jesus baptized
by John The baptist,
they have Jesus come to John the Baptist
and they say, I want to be baptized.
And John Benson says, oh
no, I shouldn't baptize you.
You're the big Kahuna. You're bigger
than I am. I should, you know,
I'm not worthy to untie your sandals.
So I should be baptized by you.
You shouldn't, I shouldn't
be baptizing you. And Jesus
says, no, no, no, it's okay.
Baptize me.
And so he does it.
And then you have the confession and
the voice from heaven and that sort of
thing.
Notice what's going on here.
The Gospel writers are very concerned
because they know that it could be
interpreted that John Bad Tizen,
Jesus makes John Superior to Jesus
and makes Jesus a disciple of John.
And they're not comfortable with that
because of course they believe Jesus is
the Messiah. And so he's therefore
superior to John The baptist.
And John the Baptist was just a
prophet or a precursor to Jesus.
So the story is told to play down this
baptism a bit and make Jesus come out as
insisting on the baptism, wanting to
do it for the right kinds of reasons,
but not making Jesus a disciple of John.
And also this tradition about the baptism
of Jesus is in different sources in
different ways.
So again,
scholars say the baptism of John the
Baptist baptizing Jesus doesn't look like
something early Christians would make up.
In fact,
you can even see that they try to
tone down its implications so it's not
something they are likely to make up.
It kind of goes against their tradition
of raising Jesus up completely and
therefore it may be historical.
Notice what we've got.
Then we've got two very small details
that a lot of scholars would say probably
our historical because they seem to be
witnessed by more than one source and
they also seem to go against
the theological tendency
of the documents in which
they're found and they
frame the gospel of Jesus,
the baptism of Jesus at the beginning
of his ministry and the charge on the
cross at the end of his ministry.
And now I'm going to back up those
those two events. Let's just say,
I'm going to argue that those two are
certain historical events in the life of
Jesus and then we'll fill in
some of the other details later.
But right now let's talk about method.
How did I get here? First method,
first little rule,
and this is something that a lot of
people use when they do historical Jesus
research.
It took all the 20th century for people
kind of develop these rules and to spell
them out in scholarship. But this is
kind of where we are now. The first rule,
multiple attestation.
Yeah.
That means when you have more than one
independent source that has a saying or
an event about Jesus,
you tend to give it a little more weight.
Now, of course, what
are independent sources?
If you have something in
both Matthew and Luke,
that doesn't count as two
independent sources, right?
Because both Matthew and Luke could
have been gotten that from mark or they
could have gotten it from queue.
But if you have something in mark
and you have something in John,
well those are two independent sources.
If you also have something in the gospel
of Thomas that most of us scholars
would say,
well they've got,
some people say the gospel of Thomas
May have known the other gospels,
but most of us will say we're going to
treat him as an independent source cause
his, he's not verbatim quoting the
other gospels most of the time.
So if you have an event or a saying that
occurs in mark and John and Q are in,
got in Thomas,
those are three independent sources.
What if it also occurs in
Paul Paul's letters? Ah,
there's another independent
source as we'll see that there.
There are some places where Paul gives
us a little clue about something and then
obviously you can take Q as
being one of those sources.
So if something is in both Matthew
and Luke but it's not in mark,
then you can say it's in queue.
And sometimes people would even say you
have one form of a parable that seems to
have occurred in queue and you have a
different form of that parable that seems
to occur in mark. And
then you can say, okay,
we have this one parable
in two independent sources.
One is Q and one is mark,
but that's kind of complicated because
of course the very definition of what's
in queue is something is in both Matthew
and Luke, but not in mark usually.
But if something's in more than
one source, it fits this criteria.
Now remember criteria is the
plural criterion is a singular.
Okay,
second
the,
actually let me illustrate this again.
One of the things that the sign of the
cross is one of the things cause it got
the divorce.
Sangs is another situation according
to mark 10 and Matthew 19 you have this
saying what God has joined together,
let no man put asunder and then
you have a few other things.
Clearly Jesus in this passage is teaching,
no divorce for his disciples,
no divorce at all, period. None
against the rule to get divorced.
But then Matthew five 32 has a parallel
with Luke 1618 which makes it look like
a Q source and that has this v wording.
Every man who divorces his
wife and marries another
commits adultery and whoever
marries a woman who has been divorced
by her husband commits adultery.
In other words,
there's another teaching on divorce here,
both of which forbid it also
forbids divorce and remarriage,
but it's not the same wording as in mark.
So scholars say that looks like a Q
saying on divorce in which Jesus still
forbids divorce and remarriage, but it's
not the same wording as the mark saying.
So we have two separate
sayings in different wordings,
but they both have Jesus
forbidding divorce and at
least divorce and remarriage.
One in Q one in mark two independent
sources is, it's really neat.
Then we find Paul in First Corinthians
seven 10 through 11 says this,
so this is Paul, a quotation from
Paul to those who are married,
I command that is Paul.
And then he says,
not I but the Lord also Paul even knows
he's quoting a saying of the Lord Jesus.
So he goes on to say that the woman must
not separate from her husband if indeed
she does separate,
let her remain unmarried or be reconciled
to her husband and Amanda does not put
away his wife.
Now most of us believe that's Paul's
wording because you can tell the way he's
kind of fudging around with
some of the details of the same,
but at least Paul gives a witness that
he knows of an anti divorce saying by
Jesus.
Also three separate independent witnesses
that Jesus taught against divorce.
One from mark that Matthew copies one
from Q that both mark and Matthew and Luke
have and one from Paul.
So that passes the multiple attestation
rule but it also passes the next rule,
which is this similarity.
Yeah.
When you find something in a source occur
early Christian source that seems to
go against the very inclinations of
that source or of early Christianity,
it has. Um, it's more
likely to be historical
something that swims against the
tide of early Christian expectation.
Now why does the divorce divorce thing
is multiple attested is also present the
this similarity thing, because
almost all of these, except for mark,
they both seem to know that Jesus
prohibited divorce entirely.
But then they go on to modify the rule
a bit because I mean let's face it,
people get divorced early Christians
got divorced. So Paul says, okay,
well you're not as good words,
but if you do get divorced
then you should do this.
So that very riders who pass on an anti
divorce saying also fudge the saying
just a bit,
which shows that the saying is more
radical than their own ethics are.
In other words,
the anti divorce saying is dissimilar
to the right practices are these early
Christians. It's more radical than
they get themselves practicing.
And that's a clue that the saying
itself goes back to the historical Jesus
according to this method.
So dissimilarity is any kind of thing
that doesn't fit early Christian
tendencies. The sign on the
cross, I talked about that.
It wasn't a confession of Jesus,
the baptism of John.
It's not something that likely would
have invented. Um, there's another one,
the swords at Jews,
his arrest and cardiac and mark 1447
and it's followed by Matthew and Luke.
Somebody had a sword at Jesus' arrest
in the garden and somebody used it
according to the different traditions.
It was Peter,
according to John and somebody may there
others don't name somebody whacked off
the hype,
the era of the high priest slave.
But there's these different stories
about Jesus. Somebody in Jesus,
his entourage was armed.
And in some of the sources,
one of the sources, there are two
of them on. There are two swords.
Others is one sword. Now I
think this is historical. Why?
Because all the gospel writers want to
go out of their way to say Jesus was not
mounting a violent revolution. He
was not a criminal. He was not.
This was not an armed rebellion.
He's completely innocent of any political
charge of insurrection. But if Paul, if,
if Jesus's disciples were armed with
swords at his arrest in the middle of the
night at the Passover in Jerusalem,
that's insurrection. Folks,
the Romans did not allow Jews just to
go around in the middle of the night and
gardens carrying swords
for a Jew to be armed at the Passover.
An especially dangerous time that the
Romans were really worried about for a Jew
to be armed,
following around a guy who some people
were saying was the king of the Jews,
you can be arrested for that.
You can be crucified for that.
So I don't think early
Christians invented it.
I think some of these early Christians
knew that at least one and possibly more
of Jesus' disciples were armed.
It is arrest.
So that's another.
Why do I see that?
Cause it's not something they
would invent it. In fact,
that goes against their tendency.
There's another passage,
mark 10 18 mark 10 18 which is also in
Luke 1819 you may have come across this,
the man comes and ask Jesus about
what should I do have turned a live?
What's the good thing for me to do?
And Jesus says, why do you call?
Why do you ask me about the good?
There is no one good but God.
Now apparently mark riding that
didn't have a theological hiccup,
but now let me, I, you know,
I'm a good episcopalian. Okay,
why should you ask Jesus about the good?
God's the only one who is good.
Sound weird.
If Jesus is actually God,
then you wouldn't say it like that.
In other words,
this sounds like whoever's this saying,
it sounds like Jesus himself
is denying that he's God.
Don't ask me about the good.
The only who knows about good is God
and he just goes on answer the question.
I think this saying was actually something
like this was said by the historical
Jesus. Why? Because early followers of
Jesus believed Jesus. Jesus was God.
In some sense. I don't think this
is something they would invent.
It goes against their confession.
It goes against their theology,
so it's one of these cases where it's
dis similar to their faith and therefore
we tend to give it higher grade.
When it comes to a
historical has historicity,
a couple of other
criteria are a bit weaker.
These are the two
strongest social coherence.
This is when you say you see something
that is either anachronistic and it
doesn't look like it would fit in with
the life of Jesus or it does fit very
well with the life of Jesus.
If I decide, for example,
on lots of different other things that
I've decided are historical because of
these other reasons,
and then something looks like a saying
of Jesus looks like its apocalyptic and
I've already established that
Jesus was an apocalyptic prophet,
then I'm going to say, well, it
coheres with the social situation of,
of Jesus as an apocalyptic Prophet in
Galilee or take a negative example in
Matthew 18 there are a lot of rules
about what you should do in the church.
The very word church is used.
Almost all of us scholars would say a
lot of that stuff in Matthew 18 about the
church, the church rules, a church
leadership. That's not historical. Why?
Because the church didn't
exist in Jesus' lifetime.
Jesus sounds like he's giving rules
about a constitution for a church,
but we think that's anachronistic.
The church is something that
developed after Jesus' death.
When his followers came to believe
that he had been raised from the dead.
And then they should continue doing
things in his name, but in Jesus,
his own lifetime traveling around Galilee,
talking about now when you have the
church, you should meet on Sundays.
I think for Easter you should
wear white. Um, you know,
Jesus didn't do this sort of thing.
So that all of that stuff in Matthew 18,
that looks very much
like a later church life,
we believe was read back into the life
of Jesus by the author of Matthew or
other people. And then
the last thing is, uh,
the last criterion is rather we,
it's call the coherent coherence.
And this basically just says,
if you can establish something as being
historical about Jesus by these other
stronger criteria, and then something
else seems to cohere with it,
then you can kind of throw it in the pot.
But it's a very loose kind of criteria
to use for historical purposes.
Now. So where are we?
That's the methodology.
If we're going to come up with
some basic ideas about Jesus.
Here's where I would say I would end
up with, and there's some of this,
it's very controversial.
I would say though that Jesus
was an apocalyptic prophet,
an apocalyptic Jewish prophet.
One of the reasons that Jesus,
his life was framed by
two apocalyptic events.
If Jesus was baptized by John the Baptist
and John the Baptist seems clearly to
have been preaching some
kind of apocalyptic message
about the coming kingdom.
That means I think that Jesus was
originally a follower of John the Baptist,
although the later gospel writers,
we'll play that down.
If Jesus was a follower of an
apocalyptic Jewish prophet,
I think that at least means
that hit the beginning of his,
his own ministry was wreathed in that
apocalyptic Jewish prophecy kind of world,
and he was executed on a charge of
sedition as being the king of the Jews
against the law.
Only the Roman Senate got to make kings
and if Jesus was going around claiming,
and,
and I'm not saying he was claiming,
but if other people were claiming
that he was the king of the Jews,
the only way to understand that I think
in this situation is that he believed
that he was going to be the messiah
that would come at the end of time and
overthrow the Romans.
So his death was also apocalyptic.
The temple incident.
We could talk about that.
We did Jesus go in and throw the money
changes out and cleanse the temple as it
said.
I think that's historical.
It goes against the tendency of the
gospels to portray Jesus as nonviolent and
non confrontational in that last week.
I think he therefore did it.
What did it mean?
I think this is more debatable.
I think it was a prophecy meant to enact
what he saw was becoming the future
destruction of the temple by God
in some kind of apocalyptic event.
At the end of time,
I think Jesus was therefore a lower
class Jewish peasant who spoke mainly
Aramaic.
I think he had a group of disciples
of 12 I won't go into some of these,
but I think he actually did form 12 of
his disciples to be an inner core group.
I think even that's apocalyptic.
Why would he have 12 disciples?
Why do you choose the number 12 because
there were 12 tribes of Israel that
would be reconstituted at the end of time,
according to Judas expectation.
I think there are also women.
There were part of his inner circle,
and this is because women later in early
Christianity were marginalized from
leadership positions,
but there's all kinds of evidence from
the resurrection narratives to the
presence of Mary Magdalene to other
women that they were part of his inner
circle of disciples. I think that he
never taught the end of the Jewish law,
but I think he did teach
what was something,
a liberalizing version of the Jewish law.
In other words,
that you're the ethical treatment of
other your fellow human beings counted as
more important than actual details
of observing the Jewish law,
such as keeping kosher, washing
your hands, keeping the sabbath.
What did Jesus think he was the Messiah?
I think this is a really big problem.
I don't know.
There seem to be places where he makes
no open claim to Messiah ship in his
ministry except in the gospel of John,
members of the gospel of John. Actually,
we tend to treat that as less historically
reliable in these things because it
looks very much more Christian
theological confession.
But in the synoptic gospels,
Jesus doesn't make open
claims to being messiah.
On the other hand, he was executed
for being king of the Jews,
so the Romans at least thought he was
claiming to be the messiah or they thought
that other people were
claiming that about him.
Okay,
but what he thought himself is very
difficult. One of the things though,
I can see, I think we can say for
sure, this is where I'll end today.
Jesus himself,
I believe,
never saw himself as the
founder of Christianity.
He didn't think about himself
as starting a new religion.
I believe he saw himself as preparing
the people of Israel to make them ready
for the apocalyptic inbreaking of God.
There was to happen.
At the end of time,
or at the end of our time,
and the setting up of a new
time of the Kingdom of God,
the Kingdom of Israel that would
incorporate the whole world.
So the way I would do this,
as Jesus was an apocalyptic Jewish prophet
who was executed because the Romans
at least believed that he was,
he or his disciples were making dangerous
claims that he was the king of the
Jews. That's all you get
on the historical Jesus.
Sorry.
Next time we start on Paul,
see you next time.